you suffered from racial inequality if
you've suffered from gender inequality
you would be completely justified in the
fact that you are not achieving the
things that other people who didn't have
those disadvantages have achieved and I
say this as a white guy who was born in
America to a doctor father I understand
that but at the same degree you have the
opportunity that Chris nor I have which
is that you can be an inspiration to
people who just went through the same
thing and succeeded comma despite those
circumstances because I can promise that
there is somebody who has had it worse
and has done it better and I think power
follows the blame finger if you point it
to the government the government has the
power if you point it at your spouse and
say like it's their fault that I'm not
in shape you're giving them all the
power until you're like it's my fault
it's also responsibility what is what if
it's not your fault it doesn't matter
and